good morning millennial morning
Millennials my voice is almost back I'm
I'm not I don't miss it I'm not gonna
lie
that is a menacing why you see everyone
with their sensitivities you sound nice
we do maybe several stories II know but
I meant to howl at it it's pleasing okay
well you haven't gotten that when you
sang my sticky shoes you literally tell
me every time you make me do a concert
on every time I lose my voice um Kristen
texted me in the middle the toast
yesterday she was like you sounds so
sexy mm-hmm enjoy it while it lasts
because you'll be back - what do they
call us some vocal fry' you know about
us yeah that's what people say about us
you know what I really appreciate when
people have like legitimate concerns
like when people complain about like oh
they talk so annoying like a fair point
you know I'm not gonna disagree with you
let's understand is that this is how we
were born like we don't right that's
igniting fun of someone who has like a
big mole on their face it's just the way
that they were born right or like I
don't go out of my way to talk like this
if anything I think my talking has
improved a lot in my life when we if you
watch our Bat Mitzvah videos like when
we were kids we were the most obnoxious
voice is very very thick New York accent
Long Island like Gina from real house is
important we were Junie
we were Gina Elena Jackie and Claudia I
want to thank everyone Mazel Tov you
look so beautiful tonight like this
every most amazing night and it was
coming out of kids like it was so weird
no we were fifty year old women living
inside ten year old right so we
definitely like gotten better since then
and I really do think I mean you can
always improve but this might just be
the best eggs if you're gonna talk [ __ ]
about me online which I know some of you
are um I appreciate when you bring up
legitimate concerns like you know my
voice is annoying I can agree with you
but like they're not even funny like
that's a lie
so don't say that right they're not even
gorgeous right I if you're gonna like
talk [ __ ] like be legit touch it be
legit also watching watch what happens
like last night and Annie said -
Stephanie he was like you and Brandi
have a little girl helium voices which
by the way is a way nicer way of saying
it yeah call us up and she was like yeah
it's we just do like they just do
everyone
a different voice don't hate I watch the
entire episode of watch her up and live
on mute last night so I have no idea
what happened but they were looking
wonderful yeah when I got to TP geez
it was on like mute muted we hung out
last night and like I asked him to turn
it on and like get in here and then we
just never got to watch it you know um I
only watched half it was cute there he
recorded it I don't think it was
pre-recorded there in New York right now
so oh they are on the toast and honestly
I just I need some time with wait time
with my girl and I need some time with
LAN but totally also mazur announcement
this morning for all of our Android
toasters and just anyone who likes to
listen to Spotify the morning shows is
now available on Spotify which is a very
prestigious saying any podcast can't
just show up did you know that no I know
it's a long month in the me we just
signed a contract so if you have an
Android if you're not loving the podcast
app I've heard some people have like
great with the podcast app yeah we are
now available on Spotify every episode
is gonna be available on Spotify when
it's available in the podcast app so
very exciting stuff it's just so
exciting because Spotify is like my
favorite well what's obviously my
favorite music streaming app but it's
one of my favorite apps overall I'm like
teaching on it The Aviator it's like a
mi Ariana Grande
so I told you that now like now that I
can see all my clothes like I haven't
worn this shirt in like three years just
cuz I like forgot about it you know do
you have the shirt is it from your NYU
days when you were awarded downtown girl
grungy this is so downtown hittin the
streets I know as like an uptown lady
it's not exact but you've you've paired
it nicely you know you're bringing your
downtown roots with you uptown so it's
just like I feel like my wardrobe is
gonna expand I'm just watching everyone
so everyone saying congratulations
Michelle congratulations Michelle now
we've got a by the air force
Congrats amazing
we had another announcement what was it
Oh today I will be recording a very
special episode for our patreon with
Danielle Bernstein of we were what we've
gotten so many requests for there are
two spectrums to the Alberta see like
there are people who are out here in the
stands [ __ ] cheering for her like
fighting everyone in the comments and
then there are people like really
affecting you to her and that's her
friend I love her so I want to talk to
her just be like do you know why people
love you and you know I believe like I
just how do you do it like she seems to
know unfazed
yeah it's like we can't stop talking
about it right but like you have to be
you really do or else what's the point
like if you're just gonna be brought
down by other hate regardless of how
much you love you have yeah you don't
deserve no she does a really good job I
don't like I don't know if it's a front
but she does a really good job was like
now that you're not giving a [ __ ] which
is impressive because I pretend it's not
give a [ __ ] but you've got you've got
giving less hits over the years for sure
but like I still it comes in waves like
some days I'm like [ __ ] these people I'm
better than everyone grab spoon and eat
my ass I'm and then some days I'm like
crippled by the hey J don't like me like
it's just it depends on the day by the
way I had two glasses of wine last night
and then you know I never drink wine why
first of all I was like up like
literally blackout drunk
and it's like a nice strong nobody worst
night's sleep of my life I jumped in my
legs oh yeah it was terrible I never do
it again
oh really such a treat like you know
especially now that you're in Uptown
lady's right you're not gonna have
tequila and then stumble home and I got
to TP G's at like 10:30 so my god Mike I
started drinking hard to kealan now so
you know what's the Milagro
what's that the rosary that everyone
loves is it blogger I don't know I'm not
no no sorry that's tequila
what is the rose a with M that's in like
a short fat bottle the bottle literally
looks like my body you have to look it
up it's looking at about out of nothing
Miraval oh it's like this little short
fat bottle and it was like it was nice I
was having a good time like and I was
getting like a good drunk and then I got
home and I was like wasted and Ben was
like what did you doing like I had a
glass of wine too too heavy pours and
with a new alcohol it's just so II you
never know how it's gonna hit you
sideways that's so true and then what
was the third announcement we had oh
we're gonna do tear toasters today that
whoa yeah you're welcome everyone and
make sure that you were watching the
polka King because that's work
assignment we're gonna call on you and
why I haven't heard anyone talking about
not one you think there's a master post
in the toasters group people check us in
their Instagram stories yeah
Instagram stories I haven't seen one
thing here you guys not watching it are
you guys not interested
we're both watching on YouTube say
please leave me a comment write know
you're the transition we can transition
we couldn't we always can we could
transition to the choice web showing the
week and then we just make everyone
watch our show yeah like old episodes
also I'm really like I'm on this Joe
Rogan thing and I just I need everyone
to take a break whether you're listening
right
or in the future as a podcast take a
break go over the podcast app leave us
five stars and subscribe and just do
stuff because I want to be Joe Rogan and
also if you're listening to this as a
podcast right now then you're able to do
other things on your phone at the same
time including leaving us a review
totally and I know that a lot of our
toasters are out here in some of the
affected areas by hurricane Florence and
I just want to make sure everyone's okay
and taking proper precautions like
whether it's evacuating or boarding up
your house just I wanted to make sure
everyone's being taken care of if we're
having an enough snack and then also
selfishly I need help because me and Ben
are supposed to go to Porter we go
tomorrow
and everyone I'm telling their ID nuts
there's a hurricane and there's also a
tropical storm in a photo Rico and I do
believe that we can cancel without
financial penalty because I'm like bet
if they're charging us work go look
we'll sit in the hotel all day I don't
care we're not paying for trip we're not
going on but and I keep looking at the
maps but you can't believe the weather
like he's the hurricane affecting Puerto
Rico I don't know but all I can look at
is history and this time last year the
hurricane was affecting Puerto Rico but
just when you say hurricane of Puerto
Rico it's like yes of course so I don't
know I should have ethanol yeah or just
like weather on the one I looked it up
and it's just like so confusing but see
look it's not the hurricane that's not
hitting New York but its rained every
day for about two weeks straight we're
getting like hurricane shrapnel should
by shrapnel right no no shrapnel is um
nothing no with the shrapnel
no but shrapnel is like pieces of metal
okay sorry what we're gonna do the D
hurricane uh like what's the word with a
D that's like oh uh diet picking I need
something to happen it's not just
disbursements
it's like my brain right what debris
we're getting debris debris from the
hurricane
so yes so it's like well you know maybe
is a hurricane gonna hit part of you go
no but if they're gonna debris as well
just like the aftermath like that right
you're not gonna have great weather so
no matter do we change our trip and then
I'm just yeah Kelsey Bellamy needs in
Mexico but it's raining there too
someone I know I felt in scrims in
Jamaica and it's raining there too so
it's like do we just cancel and go
somewhere else or just like postpone
like you packing you postpone right yeah
and you should do like a little
staycation go to Atlantic City in New
York at an Atlantic City is not relaxing
debris no the stream is like 80 seconds
no no 15 seconds delayed from our actual
in real time talking that's just the way
live streams so it's like all the time
really cuz we're like yeah anyways
that's hilarious
you should probably cancel your trip I
know and now we're within the 24 hour
range like we have to make some moves
yeah I mean regardless of even if a
hurricane hits there or not like you're
not gonna have good weather so right
what's something okay fine but where
should I go next
oh oh the other like places I would want
to go like a room but they're all in the
same area right no no um I think you
just have to move your tribe like it is
hurricane season or I could do like a
lodge a Veronica Lodge you would hate
that yeah or you could go to like looks
good because my birthday's tomorrow hey
chief are Eric oh and I'd be missing it
look at that when one door closes open
doors a party a very small window like
I'd rather be Puerto Rico no offense I
love you Eric but you know what it's
something and then you know we can hang
out and can do the show on Monday with
me oh that's so true
and you're really exciting is that I
think we couldn't officially say
summer's over like I know about me okay
summer is just in the weather and like
I'm coming I try to get a cab today me
too because I can and because I'm
[ __ ] done with ride-sharing apps
downloaded lyft
canceled on me twice I haven't yeah I
can't get that a universe doesn't want
me to get to the shows I had two failed
movers before I got in a cab and new
boots to fooders and that's I don't even
[ __ ] know it's just so hard like and
it's like he wasn't even numerous fault
this time thinks I'm not I'm gonna go
off on Travis kalanick whatever his name
is
okay it was the streets of New York stop
because they don't let you turn so then
uber driver just can't pick me up is it
the governor election today it is the
primary it's a big day I mean I'm not
voting because I don't know enough about
it but I encourage other people to do
research and vote it's important that
everyone votes except for me but it's
like it's a primary and how many
candidates are in the primary right now
I only know of obviously I know it's in
and governor I know but homo no homo
right that's so there's it's honestly I
don't know anyone's policies but she
should win just for that slogan it seems
to me there's only two candidates but
isn't there more but isn't that what we
choose from on the day and also right
now are we choosing between home Owens
mo cuz there could only be one Democrat
right there running on the same party I
think that's why today's work so those
commercials are gonna end soon from one
way or another
but one of them's gonna he's gonna but
the ones attacking no other no honestly
like I'm just I don't know politics and
I'm not really I'm not speaking from a
political standpoint but I'm so here for
something exiting to be mayor just like
no sorry governor governor imagine that
[ __ ] in Albany just like to my show in
Albany tickets available at crow [ __ ]
calm I feel like you think it's cool to
be governor of like New York the most
cosmopolitan city in the world but you
live in Albany right no it's like you
think that the governor of New York like
lives in the Empire State Building
Gracie Mansion yeah no she lives in
Albany and it sucks well he or whoever
it's like whoever the Crown Victoria is
very exciting we should run for governor
changes you know mayor mayor is where is
that Bethany should run for mayor
that's an amazing idea uh-huh I think
about like who cuz you can't complain
about the mayor all the time without
having a better suggestion like like
those people who complain about stuff
and like say no to everything well you
have to come up with another hand right
so like and that's that's what I'm doing
cuz I complain about traffic the mayor
all the time and also bring but also
bring ideas solutions Bethenny we need a
business person and a germophobe in the
mayoral office or Lisa Rinna she would
just wet wipe the whole city Lisa Rinna
I mean she would be good in some aspects
but you know you really do like it is
you are managing a city it's like a
business it's ablaze yes Bethenny can
organize the biggest private relief
effort of all time she can relieve us of
some of this public urination but then
also we're excited there yes to believe
I [ __ ] up the joke and it's like she
like goes hard unlike people who on
scoundrels like Ramona like Sonja when
she was being a cheetah grand
and like that's what she would do to all
the employees of the city for that seat
I know that was a really tough scene for
me to watch did you see all the girls
showing up and the new housewife Barbara
home phone whose phone number I have to
get because we know each other
we have a picture can I text you a
picture to put up of me and the new
housewife Jake I'm gonna message it you
want Facebook okay that's so exciting I
did see the video of all of them not all
of them the Flex few the mochi roots
going in supporting Bethany skinny girls
jeans at Macy's and I'm just so excited
that they're filming like and things are
happening like in real time you know we
don't have to wait I couldn't agree more
I usually do money can't buy you class
forever
found it okay it's me so I know this new
housewife through the points guy and
when me and the points guy went to the
Cabaret with the countess it was Barbara
who gave us the tickets and she was so
cool and so funny and so nights and like
music fell in love and I never got to
post the pictures cuz the next night I'm
like the next day our lives were ruined
but I hate when my life gets right after
I meet the countess and I never found it
great money can't buy you class you
sound like the countess with your voice
oh my god hashtag the countess and
friend
so Barbara Sonja and LuAnn all showed up
for the Skinnygirl launch at Macy's I
tried to buy Skinnygirl teams in there
sold out really yeah in my size which is
like a big size we go to Macy's we
should go anyway like is it's fall
I want those burgundy ones that's only
close and there's nowhere to get new
fall fashions like Macy's actually I
actually bought new fashions Jake is a
mature I bought new fashions from boohoo
last night because I went out eight so
it's like to do my you know bi-weekly
order and there was nothing there was
nothing out here for me it's getting
really hard these days who had amazing
[ __ ] like a night but it's like it's the
whole website like the whole website was
50% off I got 12 items for 188 dollars
it was scary I know but it looked really
cute and like I was watching Sydney
white and I was just like feeling
empowered to like I don't know get close
do you know any no I totally know what
you mean
I'm getting there too and it's like even
if not all of it is great like at least
half of it will be and you didn't spend
that much and like you could always
think I don't like about boohoo is that
they don't give you a label you have to
pay for it oh yeah right ASOS literally
puts their label in the bag for you so
you just put
literally no matter how big it is I
shove it into our mailbox I literally
hate doing returns like I would rather
wear the ugly thing for a year course
then return something I don't ever turn
then you end up like you and now I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna segue into our
first story because one place that
actually does a great job with returns
and makes it so easy for me and my my
return is in the mail before I even put
the new clothes in my closet revolt is
revolves speaking of birth is being
accused of fat shaming with a sweatshirt
meant to shine light on the horrors of
trolling it's a picture up we're putting
that's me Barbara Barbara's in the
middle tbh cheese on the Left I want to
see um I looking really drunk
Tom cuz yeah I was being chunky I was
being I was so drunk that was the first
night I ever had a margarita because I
got to oh my god that's so probably not
possible I guess you only started
reading tequila Wow
yes and then I was like what do people
who drink tequila drink and then I went
to tbg we met for a drink before and he
had ordered me a margarita and it was
like so delicious and now I only turn
margaritas that's so amazing with
Barbara yeah she was cool
okay back to revolving this and your
asks and my amazing segue right which
was all for naught
they put on a sweatshirt called being
with graphic writing being fat is not
beautiful it's an excuse so did you know
the back story behind this so these and
by the way once you see it out of
context it's absolutely horrible and
then when you get the context it's like
a little bit better but not really this
is a collaboration between revolve and
that brand that they carry LPA or IPA
it's yeah it's LPA and it's the brand is
LPA and it's called the Paloma
sweatshirt so they're doing this like
anti cyberbullying campaign in
partnership with like lena dunham and
cara delevingne and a bunch of other
celebs whose management team is
obviously not in tune with what's
necessary and so they basically we're
launching like a line of sweatshirts I
don't like some of the meanest things
people have written on social media and
like putting it on a sweatshirt and they
were also be released at the same time
and it would have made I think a little
bit more sense but one of them got
leaked by accident and went on sale
first and there's so many things I need
to point out here one it's just like so
funny like not funny but like funny how
like they're celebrities who have like
teams of people who are responsible like
for looking out for their business their
image
their star and like someone let this
happen
do you know what I mean even even
regardless of just the one item slipping
like this whole collection is a [ __ ]
horrible idea like the whole point of
trolls is like we're supposed to be
above it and ignore it but no you want
to [ __ ] put on spectra to make
someone pay eighty dollars and there are
so many ways to like highlight
cyberbullying and all of that but this
like who the [ __ ] would wear this and by
the way if someone's wearing this down
the street like that's a fence they
don't know the message you don't know
that revolve did a cop with a car with
LPS show my spread on mention it uh
mention it all wait here's the best part
Jackie the sweatshirt when it went on
sale was only available up to a size XL
so it's like the whole point is like and
I started building it skinny people
would be wearing this horrible makes you
look even worse and I started a t-shirt
and you know what's so funny is that if
this if it was another company like
forever 21 like so many more people
would be talking about it like
influencers would be like out of here
but Rabab has every [ __ ] influencer
on their payroll and they're not allowed
to talk about it so it's just like so
funny how nobody's posting about it
except for like legit me because I'm
with the holiday and me and um Eddie
Jenko from Blue Bloods you know that's a
race called like the only people no
one's talking about it because like
revolve has every media company
publication website influencer on their
payroll so no it's not matter like
literally the only website I saw traded
up
was Mike oh I'm on oh now I'm on USA
Today
yeah I don't exactly know buddy cool
like right know like E news isn't no
putting a picture out there on the red
carpet at the revolve house right like
getting money quotes from influencers oh
and the spot shirt is $170
so if you wanted to create yourself in
an ugly cropped sweater that really only
someone anorexic can pull off and you
know exhale like in revolve terms like
it really fits like a medium um feel
free to spend $180 on it you're welcome
I don't even think it's available
anymore yes it does like poorly poorly
done and I love revolve like and I feel
like they do they're really like smart
cool brand there are some things that
they need to like evolve on but I think
in general like well this is just ironic
Jerry because like they they perpetuate
such a negative body image in the sense
like everyone they hire and everything
when certain model and celebrity that
they bring he's like literally my way
around or above 110 pounds I'm like one
time they they brought Ashlee Graham and
they know that they thought they were
like [ __ ] revolutionary
progressiveness who like are changing
the world like they never brought her
back again like please they yes they're
cool and their parties are cool and they
bring people from the bathroom like you
know we're supposed to think they're
cool but like I'm really over it and
this like takes me to the next level
like until they bring me to the revolve
house to perpetuate a realistic body
image I'm done with you they did reach
out to you and she never responded right
they are busy with this right no that
was no good response I just want to say
I didn't reach out to us bring us to the
house and it's like one to give us free
clothes which I never got so which is
also fine okay you know did you get it
right don't know about cuz you want now
we're not gonna get ya know why now
we're not getting you I don't know why
why big it's not being fat wow I can
thanks even worse that is such a
terrible thing to say and like this is
what's so [ __ ] up about the world we
live in ready you can put that on a
sweatshirt and like world will go on
revolve will be unaffected I mean you
can't say the word diet anyways just
some food for thought this morning yeah
that was crazy when I saw it I was like
this has to be like like no one would
actually do that you know but then
putting it in context it makes a little
bit more sense to a horrible idea
were they executed and it's like anyone
will do anything just to be like
socially relevant like if there's no
like you can't just do [ __ ] like
this just to do it cuz then you end up
with [ __ ] like this that makes no sense
and it's out of touch know someone
really really thought this was a good
idea a bunch of people and that's what's
so scary like someone sewed this on a
shirt and like felt good about it yeah
and like someone someone pitched this in
a business meeting in a conference room
and was like and had other people's like
we're making shake like we're making
strides well and anyway I guess we could
say goodbye to our free clothes but
revolve needs to put the evolve and
revolve totally yeah okay without
further ado here are the fat side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
so was that not and you just got a bonus
yes because you know what there's a lot
of news and there's a
world news and I want to talk about it
but first we must talk about garbage
bachelor in paradise is boarding Kimball
and Jenna Cooper breakup amid cheating
scandal it's really so crazy
she's a legit con artist they should
make a movie about her did you see her
statement yeah [ __ ] about just about
[ __ ] bout [ __ ] what's up from that guy
Katy Perry's husband Russell Brand oh
yeah Arthur George wasn't Steve
Forgetting Sarah Marshall Russell Brand
what sees Alice what's his snow out of
snow
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what was the
story China Cooper statement was that oh
yes she basically just denied the whole
thing and Jordan like justice justice
this is the what he put out on Instagram
black and white photo definitely with
the pensive gentleman look to think to
feel to fall these emotions interact
with experiences and people when you
find a person you think about them wait
feel I feel like an interpretive dance
needs to be done to the statement and I
feel like we have the woman to do it oh
for sure you can do like you know what I
really feel like I need to be behind the
trees okay just everyone I think you
should take your microphone off for a
second no no okay okay and for the
podcast listeners you like to imagine I
want to head over to YouTube or maybe
we'll clip it for our Instagram channel
I think it's gonna need that okay that
moving okay running okay this is like
slam poetry exactly are you ready to
think to feel to fall these emotions
interact with experiences and people
when you find a person you think about
them you feel when they feel and
sometimes you fall when you're in love
with even the experiences you had with
them it's something to respect can you
good look some rhythm oh yeah yeah being
careless with someone that you give your
heart to and reach milestones with
sensible isn't sensible no matter what
the terms may be [ __ ] anyways no I'm
trying Chucky I'm over here okay
literally giving the performance of a
lifetime they start again
no that's invested okay I have not had
an easy
life and having struggles allows me to
grab on to tough times and discard them
so yeah my god okay I deal with
unreasonable circumstances reasonably
and have come to terms with a decision
to remove myself from the relationship
it breaks my heart to think feel and
fall for this
it dropped me stumbling emotions and
being understanding is not easy I'll be
taking time to pursue my inner peace and
she will always have me to talk to if
you've reached out to me allow me time
thank you to those who have poetry all
right let me see ya Jesus died for our
thin the--is all right let me say that
might be like the greatest thing ever
our real plants will need to be watered
after this yeah honestly worth it wow
that looked really cool Michelle except
your face is being covered by the logo
the whole time
oh [ __ ] you're just too talk on I know
it's what everyone says like this uh
model me and my squad anyways that was
beautiful
and I feel like Jordan as the pensive
gentleman wait that's like a really
pensive that's a perfect word like very
deep profound statement by him yeah no
he definitely like he was so in love
with her and he was heavenly blinded by
love blinded to the atrocities she was
committing and for a model what a wide
vocabulary
no he's I'm into him like I've always
said that well I saw that like everyone
really likes him right now everyone
wants him to be the bachelor like take a
xanax calm down not everyone who was
wronged in this lifetime like needs to
go on The Bachelor but he like really
came around and he's like a funny dude
like when he's telling Benoit to get
like to like keep his French baguette in
his pants on its date with Jenna and to
keep his little French fingers out of
his briefcase whatever that may look
like I just like where his head's at you
know he's thinking big he's creative and
I appreciate it and it she's just more
than what they wanted you to think he
was initially on The Bachelor totally
but anyway he's not like like I'm not
saying he's like who do we love Peter
Krause of course huh but he's not you
know Robbie is he is not Robbie Hayes
and justice for the people who think
that he is because he's not anyways
I couldn't remain a film I really like I
feel like I'm maxed out with the
Batchelor stuff wellthat - I'm maxed out
with the Batchelor stuff yes which is
why now we have like a four-month break
until Colton season airs nobody's when
does he go he goes in like a week right
he goes in like a week so snitch bon
voyage
we'll miss you counselor interntional
but she needs to be know we'll be able
to attend your wedding if she's on The
Bachelor yes and I think by then she'll
be engaged to Colton first one yeah you
know what's your policy on that no ring
no ring no well ring ring living
together bring and if I know your man
really well and like I consider them a
friend of mine brings I'm pretty I was I
was hard corn than a ring no brain I
would say there's two couples who
weren't no ring no bring and like I was
I've said if one of them breaks up like
I'll be so mad I'm one of them did break
up but they both would have been invited
separately right as my friend and then
also has been threatened so I'm not sad
about that the other couple still
together so I'm holding out but it's
like if your man if your man made out
with my friend and I don't know him that
well like we did we've never like on
double dates or anything like and I just
don't know him as a person you have to
evaluate everyone like as a guest
look I know as a guest I'm a premium
guest I'll take great pictures for you I
will eat all the food people or the
money follows the hashtag I'll use the
hashtag I'll use the filter I will dance
the night away like I know I'm a premium
guess she had to evaluate everyone like
that okay so you're thinking about
inviting somebody what do they bring to
the table are they a good time will they
bring good energy will they be a good
simcha dancer like I need to know I need
to know you know yeah no I'm about I'm
evaluating all of these yeah but it's
like as someone who is a great some
financier and like will really bring the
the heat is I'm cutting right it's like
I don't need to rely on other people so
much and also like the less people
taking up my space on the dance floor
clean and be more you know I need
freedom - it was like a 10-foot radius
at all times
you should your dress should be like so
big that it creates like a diameter well
I tried on some of like those dresses
with hoops and it was like in those
terrible terrible and I think I
eventually I will change into a party
dress little mini dress
Elita little dress but like a jumpsuit
and I hope to be very little by then so
that I have my my choice my people you
never wanna
I'm not here for the diet I'm sorry I'm
just I'm fighting it even though I don't
even want to like I'm the least diet
person right but freedom of speech like
say what you wanted I'm that good really
bothers me the diet culture is like
I'm sorry nothing except annoying no
it's just it's a personal choice like we
live in a free country if you want to go
to diet and talk about it and use the D
word to use to describe it okay that's
one you know I'm gonna keep eating my
doughnuts in my bed but I'm happy for
you like you know like live your life
okay ready for the second story at 11
a.m. yeah
Dancing with the Stars 2018 season 27
cast's reveal of meet the celebs and
their pro partners okay
solo right you guys term use loosely but
the looser it's use the better chance we
ever have of getting on totally okay now
don't feel like we're that far it was a
good one I saw there's a couple here
that fall under our cat okay are very I
haven't seen all I saw were so like my
dream of my career would be so good I
would win you would win it's not really
about damn it without some tweet
followers no it's about followers it's
about dance too because if you get high
scores that you can't get eliminated
true so it's about both and the toaster
strong remember it Rob Kardashian like
almost won yeah that was crazy he was so
hot oh my god that was so long ago I
remember this is so random but our dad
was still Ivan he used to watch the
stars god you're right he watched Kim
season like we had just started watching
Kardashians he was like I'm watching
your friend a new superstar gonna
Tiffany definite we were sing ever the
weirdest Michael watches it I feel like
it engine on for it's two hours of just
like Margo watches it because like up
Simone biles she started with some on
miles and now exam number one Alexis
Wren so internality
yeah she's opening up the floodgates
even though she gets her boobs removed
so look skinnier so like right now I
talked about setting about negative body
image that's why she hangs out with it
all right but also I don't know how
that'll help her dancing will it help
will it hurt me dance I think any VIPs
to dance but maybe like you have less
move more movement you have more
movement flexibility next we have EV
Alana
Evanna Lynch who is from Harry Potter so
it's not our girl next we have Nikki
Glaser who is ask an upcoming oh my god
know what right so between her and
Alexis friend like you're looking pretty
good oh my god totally she's legit
though she's like a real comic for sure
but like Albany here you come when I was
in Raleigh they have everyone
the wall obviously that's not it
Margaret sign to to like please it's for
talent only Margot and I sign next to
Nikki Glaser because I was like female
comics doing it for themselves
yeah sister next up John Schneider limbs
it from small deletion - damn No thank
God uh Mary Lou Retton
wow you guys she's a retired gymnast who
took the gold medal at the 1984 low good
they're trying to do like the Tonya
Harding Nancy Kerrigan thing DeMarcus
Ware he's a former pro football player
who played for the Broncos and the
Cowboys I absolutely love when they get
football players because they're weirdly
good there we are good sport like
they're 11 and they like are stars also
that gymnast like has an unfair
advantage so who are you rooting for in
this NFL season we didn't even talk
about the opening Oh Cowboys sick have
wood because well I don't really care
and then every time like I suppose
something about football like everyone
yells at me because like people take it
so personally I mean it's like so I
can't choose between you or cuz there's
two teams and I don't think both of them
are good the Cowboys are max
the Cowboys are America's Team he's hot
Tony Romo his life Candice it's acute
it's to them like I just like their I
just like their inserting or a player
but uh but they're still like very
involved in that in the Cowboys culture
it's just like they just have a great
brand going you know no and the
cheerleaders and brandy and Jasmine
Redmond Redmond and Jasmine the Jasmine
good of it all right it just it's
there's so much there for like pop
culture enthusiasts I also I feel like
it's not controversial you know it's
like they're a good team like they've
always been good like they're good they
also like don't like they haven't won in
a while so like I'm ready for a win from
them right no but there's not like
rooting for the Patriots where it's like
nobody else oh I'm not like rooting for
the Jets we're like they always looks
like sometimes a Jets won last week I
know and that's how it starts I was
reading a whole thing from KFC like he
was saying he's been a Jets fan it's
always starts out good and it's never
good except they'd like this new hot guy
like Sam who we shouldn't totally on the
dose totally and Mark Sanchez next up
Adam Jones inside joke Bobby bones Ali
Sanchez I know Bobby bones he's like oh
I like that yeah me too one Hubble to
patch a he is fraught he's starring in
that flicks is full house sequel okay I
don't watch and he also was in Dallas
Mamma Mia and AD the Bible continues Wow
he's a Broadway uh
I think I think of the movie okay I
don't know she grocery store Joe which
is like of all the people that is just
so crazy and that's just like he got so
far no said we were gonna stop talking
about The Bachelor working at a grocery
store I mean better than Nick meiosis I
guess justice for Kaitlyn Bristowe when
is she going on she was promised and it
got it got taken away
Tinashe which like that seems unfair
yeah it totally um Nancy McKeon was it
she shot to fame on the facts of life as
the bad girl Joe meelo Manheim
he is from Disney Channel original movie
zombies so he probably has like oh so
far I'm not impressed yet not a
precedent yeah that's it week where are
the stars
no there's a usually someone like
controversial like Bristol Palin like
that was funny I need someone
controversial and usually there's
someone well obviously they took our
recommendations to heart is like when
Simone biles and lawyer Ned that's where
I'm like that was so unfair they're
basically professional dancers Heather
Morrison Heather Morrison is a
professional dancer but I think I would
keep the gymnast because like it is a
little different and then it's like so
Tinashe wouldn't be considered who
wouldn't normally was on that's insane
she is a professional dancer no she's
not even a dancer I don't know I just
like I miss Erika Jayne look every time
I say something about normani and that's
usually negative cuz like I don't
understand why people like her I get
like dragged on Twitter
she's like a hardcore sand chips okay
guys yeah and that's why that's
surprising she did did she win I'm room
I never even know that's all that's all
those celebrities can help for her you
have a good Sanjit but I wouldn't know
what goes down on Twitter it's literally
the most liberating thing oh my god I
forgot to limit whitter like I only know
what goes I'm more from like my news
notifications which keep me really
up-to-date on Moonves these days oh my
god I get the dru check them at all I
get so many generation les Mendez and
what les Moonves and Julie Chen are like
the two most evil people ever do you see
that thing Olivia sent to us sort of
it's there's so much drama and then like
she's on that that with the talk the
chill you know the talk the talk one day
she was out and they used that
opportunity that smack about whether bez
also what the hell is in Leslie Moonves
oh really yeah so people know me just
come last I'd be like I remain like
Claude yeah that's weird
I don't know
just something to think about anyways
next story is a person like I'm really
interested in personally and I feel like
you guys will be too but Apple did their
big announcement yesterday they
announced three new iPhones a new watch
and not much not much else
shades CNN tech fall is a time for what
have you done CNN or you would truly
know her company please until then shut
your mouth
call me when you've had some success bye
ashy fall is a time for cozy sweaters
pumpkin spice lattes and new iPhones oh
my god who wrote this two people
actually came out really they took two
people to create the most basic loser in
this line this year we're getting three
new iPhone Apple's annual September
press conference cake travels annual
apples and Newell September press
conference kicked off on Wednesday at
the Steve Jobs theater sweet on its
circular Apple park campus in Cupertino
California here's what was it what when
you think Cupertino what do you think
the way there I was gonna say that the
busy time what were you gonna say
of course what the hell's Cupertino and
why do I care about 70 and sunny apple
HQ um also it's so funny cuz yesterday I
was waiting outside for might noobert
would snitch my phone was being not well
[ __ ] and I was like you know what I
think I'm actually gonna have to get a
new phone today it's like not really
accepting charge and it's time we're
gonna form a job I have an iPhone 7 well
I I'm like I don't like to get the
newest phones and I was gonna go get
like an iPhone can't even though like
there's it's finicky I've heard some
good it's fine
some good some bad and then I was like
you know it is September they do
announce their new phones right about
now one hour later they announced three
new phones so but I don't like being the
first person I know but you're not cuz
technically the excess is is they we're
at the perfection hey I'm not loving the
X I love it a plus and X never came in a
plus I like a big phone I'm a big girl I
got big fingers oh I can't do a big
phone cuz like then I have like Kim
syndrome carpal tunnel and oh my god Ben
thinks he has carpal tunnel is so
annoying and now he thinks he has Golf
elbow
cuz when we went to Ben's family for
Russia shot not like they're all doctors
runs anesthesiologist one said Oh beat
you and and he was like telling he was
like diagnosing it's elbow and he's like
you thinking of carpal tunnel and they
told me my his golf elbow Kim Kardashian
had carpal tunnel
yeah but Ben doesn't even like be on
isn't gonna be on his home so monkey I
feel like when I think of him he's like
it's trying to get back into his
- Graham oh he's getting locked out
anyways here's what was announced the
iPhone XS and the iPhone XS max so is
that + yes okay the high-end iPhone X is
getting an upgrade and new size options
a 5.8 inch iPhone XS 999 dollars look at
Apple being all inclusive with a plus
option
thanks for both and the 6.5 inch iPhone
XS max $1,099 the max has a larger
display than the usual plus size phones
but a similar body while they're really
talking about them like females no right
but they talk they talk about iPhones
with more respect
then they talk about within like
full-figured body for a plus
whereas for women they're just say being
fat is not beautiful it's so you get it
Apple surprised with a third smartphone
the lower-end i phone XR the 6.1 inch
features a bright LCD screen comes in
variety of colors didn't they try that
one see the iPhone see Dana had that oh
my god one of the worst ones of all time
and like I had literally no respect for
anyone about it and it's like your phone
is the thing that you use most in this
world that you spend the most time with
so if you're not gonna splurge on that
like then what do you what are you
saving for know when it comes to tech I
like I'm the cheapest [ __ ] ever you
know that everything look like venmo you
for a dollar my two-year my two-year
plan isn't up guess I'm keeping my
blackberry no but when it comes to
phones like I'm like a thousand dollars
sure well that's how it should be
because it is the thing and also for us
like our whole [ __ ] life depends on
it like if I want to make $1000
considering like I'm a small business
tech owner like I really am NOT up to
date on the like this iPad is like
actually I guess I do have an iPad the
thinnest MacBook but I do have an iPhone
7 I just got the new MacBook the one
with the touch bar and like I'm very
good on it and I gotta bring it's really
changed my life and like literally
yesterday it's decided to break in all
forms he was breathing so loud like yeah
and I was like what the [ __ ] and then it
opened it in the touch bars like not
showing up the speakers busted every
time I play music it's like fuzzy it's
like well you just got it so just take
it to Apple and I'm still under the
one-year yeah and don't say what you're
about to say I know you're upset yeah
yeah and I'm not gonna say it's gonna be
smart I'm a smart woman
okay fourth story of smarts teen I'm a
spicy or the fourth story oh my god no
but it's a quick one it's just like kind
of interesting exciting for me
personally and why people are listening
right now in Spotify if you are just
like hi no no but when they give up
right White Castle is now selling the
impossible slider a vegetarian burger
nationwide oh wait I don't even know why
castle was still around it is I've never
been to a White Castle but I actually
might go now because I could go for a
veggie burger at all times
I'm actually I'm more surprised at like
McDonald's doesn't have a veggie burger
right it's like so easy for them and
like they'd really just like be moving
into the 21st century right and like
then people like me wouldn't have to
order a fish filet at 2:00 a.m. in
Nashville no but it's totally oh my god
it's weird though that like white
castles like a pioneer technically like
well they it makes sense that it would
be like a brown like this who really has
something to prove in the city but
McDonald's is like really so ahead of
their time and they're always trying to
prove that there are healthy options
even though like we know that there's
not even though they took away the
shaker salad and they won like they're
always winning a war it's like Olivia's
always going to those conferences and
she said McDonald's wins like all the
marketing Awards like they really are
like a revolutionary company totally so
it's shocking that they haven't come to
this conclusion yet it's 11:11 Make A
Wish tangible tangible got it Gucci bag
Gucci Gucci I want the store two days at
11:11 I'm gonna how to get you back
behind the chair and just like show it
let me go Chi box with like tissue
inside cuz I can't afford the bag just
the box like it'll be a brown paper bag
that says Gucci on it which actually
could pass very good you bad these days
oh my god totally they say they're
selling could you stuff that spells
Gucci wrong that's genius you see why
yeah there's just you know that's
references friends it's pronounced gucky
Gucci ins are doing really cool stuff
that like they're the coolest they're
the coolest it must be like so cool to
be on top of the world it's also like a
lot of pressure you know it's not a
pressure and with those fashion houses I
feel like they come in and out of style
yeah every 10 seconds but we're for a
while dolce gabbana was the [ __ ] and
then they called Oh Selena Gomez ugly
and now like people don't wear them but
that's just another reason to wear them
but um no but they also really like it's
also about like what they're apparently
like five years ago wearing the Gucci
logo was like fashion suicide and now
it's like I can't get enough of it and
like how many pounds right or a complete
but covered in G like the logo blazer
also but like Jill G my like their
dresses are beautiful like no matter how
many like rude comments no matter how
many people that co log right it was
Lena Gomes clap back finally she was
spotted in New York wearing a beret that
said ugly ok cool way to respond so
she's been looking like really amazing
on her Instagram maybe she stopped doing
drugs maybe perhaps it does wonders for
the skin
starting Wednesday White Castle
restaurants nationwide will offer a new
cider made entirely from plants the
impossible slide are created that sounds
like the wrong name for this burger cuz
it's definitely possible I you know the
impossible burger should be like a
burger and can barely finish it should
be wait let's come up with a better name
it should be like the the green burger
totally done the green burger comes in a
little green box as opposed to little
white ones that they do the green slider
created by california-based impossible
foods oh that would make sense though
will sell for a dollar ninety-nine cents
the pilot program began in April at
White Castle locations in New York New
Jersey and Chicago now the plant-based
burger will be sold at 377 locations in
13 days it's just so funny cuz like okay
the white castles in New York a veggie
burger would be helpful but like my
castle in like Wyoming where like real
people live like they don't need a
veggie burger no but like I don't know
sometimes abhart like a veggie burger is
a nice option even for not vegetarians
like it's assuming it tastes good it's
like not nearly it's like heavy or
sometimes it's just a nice change it up
but the only people who eat veggie
burgers are people who Kenny grill
burgers let's get that straight no one
who can can and will eat a real burger
is like oh well go for the veggie one
today sometimes that has a veggie burger
and he also he Tyrell burgers he likes a
veggie burger he does and also it's like
now like kosher people can have a we
enjoy butts up but they can't have a
real burger that's gonna say right and
vegetarians of course pescetarians these
vegans right even though it's bred vegan
yeah yes definitely it's like all they
can eat okay so why are they better I
mean I don't not even pretend to know
the first thing about vegans just I'm
gonna think they're an angry bunch cuz
they're so hungry okay speaking of being
hungry innate and angry and angry and
having a grueling daily regimen it's a
story about me Mark Wahlberg Wahlberg
reveals his grueling daily regimen okay
you guys this is insane
he put up his schedule on his interim
stories and people are freaking out
about it
like hour by hour what he does every day
it's insane 2:30 a.m. wake-up 2:40 a.m.
2:45 a.m. prayer time what does it do
between those 15 minutes like take it
down makeup should shower shave 3:15
a.m. breakfast
3:40 to 5:15 a.m. oh yeah when you have
breakfast at 3:15 a.m. do you like eggs
or do you have dinner like you know do
you have like cold pizza right munchies
5:30 a.m. post-workout meal another meal
6 a.m. shower 7:30 a.m. golf elbow 8
a.m. snack so people were freaking out
like he only calls for 30 minutes cuz he
did 7:30 golf maybe he does the machine
you know like a simulator 8 a.m. snack
EO 9:30 a.m. cryo chamber recovery
everyday 10:30 a.m. the morning toast
snack yeah 11 a.m. family time meetings
work calls Wow schedule kids go to
school that's rough
1 o'clock p.m. lunch that's like a
normal time to have lunch
II thought you woke up at 2:00 but he's
eating four times already two o'clock
meetings and work calls three o'clock
pick up the kids at school 3:30 snack EO
four o'clock work out number two
five o'clock shower 5:30 dinners family
time 7:30 bedtime
but it's like what is he training for it
just being an actor no nothing that like
he looks good but like relaxed no but
like are you doing the marathon like are
you an Olympic athlete like are you
really just training so like is this
just your lifestyle because you enjoy it
like that right this thing is so
unnecessary like I don't even think
Michael Phelps when he was training for
the Olympics would wake up at 2:30 right
and you're telling me that like this is
how you choose to live your life because
like it's the best for you and you enjoy
it but like at 2:30 a.m. when the alarm
goes off like you don't want to just
like die die no but like are you happy
that's what I wanted to ask I feel like
Mark Wahlberg is a happy man do you feel
like the dynamics between the Wahlberg
brothers they're like so interesting I
don't watch Wahlburgers is no I'm just
like I love I love Mark Wahlberg I love
what he's done for his family me too I
think he has such a good guy I love
Donnie and Jenny me too and I'm here for
all of it and if Miss if doing this is
what what it's gonna take to get you
know to rise that Wahlberg star well so
I'm just I'm so in
stating the finances of Donnie Wahlberg
because he was a new kid on the block
right I don't know if that was like
making the big bucks but like Rich ish
then that [ __ ] runs out there's no
ordinary when you have to split it
between five of them they still come out
with new music like once every ten years
but that well is dry but so he's on Blue
Bloods and he's like after Tom Selleck
he probably gets paid the most I would
say Tom Selleck makes eight hundred Rand
an episode
oh so Danny Roberts 500 yeah right right
he flies private everywhere celebrities
just like fly private like well you
don't have to have a plane to find Bobby
you can charter it and I think to
charter it goes like something if ever I
know or you just like have a friend with
a plane and their favorite show is Blue
Bloods and sudden nobody he does it like
multiplying together and now you're
saving lives okay hold on I'm getting my
calculator so he makes it 500 grand per
episode and it's 22 episodes in a season
every year so it's 11 million dollars
after tax like six lovely and then jenny
has her show so she's self [ __ ] I do
happen to know that Jenny McCarthy makes
only 250 grand a year from her show
because Sirius XM doesn't pay women
perfect um okay so between the two of
them six million twenty or twenty five
$250,000 I don't I don't follow them at
Instagram so I don't know like their
lifestyle them if they're living large
in about their means they also have wall
beneath wall burgers the show and wall
burgers those franchise which I bring up
in airports which means roads but he has
a split that with mark right but that's
a lot that franchise the other brother
pole and the mom I think like it's well
we really a success and like a friend I
think that it is you don't it's like
it's small how many how many would you
say they have please give me a moment
I'm just I'm so interested wall burgers
store locations
I'm just so interested in how he flies
private everywhere and like for his
anniversary like I know so there's like
jets martyr like people are faking it
drink it all day long oh wait oh my god
they have so many Canada Texas Tennessee
South Carolina Pennsylvania Ohio New
York New Jersey North Carolina Michigan
I've heard that they don't get along and
just the weirdest thing about all this
cuz like I have our time separating
Donnie as I do for him oh man I didn't
even realize his name is Danny in the
show it on the show no no in real life
what
oh right new clock I didn't so it's like
he's like this big macho guy I just want
to talk about
I'm in Iraq and like he's also singing
you know and an actor that's crazy and
the restaurant or so I've heard that the
Wahlberg's don't like Jenny and that
it's caused a divide but also I don't
know what I know because I just like
make up things right but I could see
that remember they had a reality show
she is the son from a previous marriage
I could see I could see that too but
like she just seems like a lovely gal
can we all just get along no I mean I'm
obsessed with her and then I went on her
show she literally couldn't be nicer and
like she could be mean because like
she's so like a little scary and I
expected her to be mean and I was okay
with it she was so nice and lovely and
like didn't have to be and I was just
like a little [ __ ] coming on her show
like to talk about Lisa right now and oh
they better watch happens live right and
Andy officiated their wedding right so
that is the jury then your setups for
success forever let's zoom into your
toasters Oh for our new toasters but try
that we're getting so many new listeners
like good for us cause like all these
people came home from a life-changing
weekend and they were like do you want
your life change and everyone listened
to this podcast right but no honestly
I've always said like if every toaster
just converts another like their best
friend to become a part of our cult like
that's doubling in size right and then
that toaster brings in someone with
tribbles eyes so dear toasters is all
read by segments it's called dear
toasters you can write in too dear
toasters at gmail.com and we'll take any
sort of advice I feel like our dear
toasters have become a little monotonous
it's like my bridesmaid my mind of our
name my coworker I love those so today I
picked some hardcore we know they have a
lot to live up to because we did a live
dear toasters at cam toast and it was
incredible like it was like by the end
it was something that way different than
when it started but it was like just so
so I picked some super weird ones and I
want to encourage you guys if you have
odd I want to do like weirder ones like
moisture but I don't want you guys
starting to make [ __ ] up
oh yeah no but this one is it very and
also your very interests okay this one I
would say is the most interesting okay
and they're all anonymous by the way so
to your toasters at Gmail we will never
reveal your identity unless you ask us
to take your time
hi the dear toasters read last week
about the girl's boyfriend who donated
his sperm inspired me to write this week
my Bujji dude you do dear to hosters
while I was gone because I don't work oh
yes we did it with Ben and he was giving
the worst meanest advice my brother and
I were born into lesbian parents so my
mom had to use a sperm donor to have us
when I was around 16 years old I started
wondering about who the donor was what
he looked like and if I had half
siblings my mom had a packet of
information about the donor like eye
color hair color ethnic background
medical history etc but nothing about
his name where he lived or anything too
personal we also knew his unique donor
number and the name of the sperm bank
where he got where he donated my
curiosity got the best of me so I signed
up for a website called donors sibling
registry comm and was instantly
connected with three of my half siblings
it was kind of weird but also cool to
know that I was related to these people
at the time and also now I have a little
interest in getting to know them I have
little interest in getting to know them
because they don't feel like real
siblings to me I did end up meeting two
of them in person but I still feel no
real connection to them fast over to the
present I'm now 24 and I know that I
have ten half siblings they've content
to contacted me to Facebook and the
movie just codes apply to a movie what
did you hear the sperm donor one now oh
so we referenced the delivery oh I
thought maybe you were no Ben the movie
I didn't see the movie
but I saw the trailer so she has ten
half siblings some of them idea for
movies some of us look similar which is
low-key spooky but again I've only
spoken to them over the internet and
don't have an urge to meet with them in
person this is where it gets interesting
my mom gave me an ancestry DNA kit for
Christmas just so I could find some of
my ancestors on both sides and where
they came from I was unaware that the
website would show all of my DNA matches
but sure enough when I logged in I saw a
majority of the half siblings I already
knew plus a few more then about two
weeks ago I got an alert for my email
that I had a new DNA match and when I
went to check it it said a man's name
underneath it and it said it was man's
name is your father I was shocked to say
the least
and my question is would you contact him
if you were Maine and if so what would
you say people have always asked me what
I would do if I ever found out who he
was and I just really don't know since I
never knew him it's not like I miss him
or need him to fill the void I couldn't
walk out on her you know right I grew up
with two loving parents so not having a
father was never big deal to me at the
same time I think it'd be cool to see if
we are similar or if he looks like my
brother when he donated sperm years ago
in
closed private donation I'm sure he
wasn't expecting this new technology
with ancestry.com and 23andme but his
children would be able to find him but
still he did not send in a DNA sample to
the websites I'm sure he did send a DNA
sample to the website so we knew that
could happen so I'm just wondering what
your thoughts and opinions are in the
situation
Wow wow that is crazy that is a story of
a movie and I'm not sure that it isn't
you know but as if I were writing the
movie this is what I say first of all
I'm in no position to tell you what to
do about this because I it's your life
it's your there's no wrong around and
like I I can't relate whatsoever however
I would say he has 10 plus he's donated
it's for 10 plus time so clearly to him
it was just sort of like a business
arrangement right like he was cashing
those sperm checks so it would guess it
would be cool to see if he looks like
you and your brother you can look him up
on Facebook to do that and to see if
you're similar but I don't know I just
feel like I couldn't see it like going
great more so then I could see it just
going weird no I'm on the same page and
I find it really shocking that with
these new technologies like there hasn't
been more of a conversation around sperm
banks because you donate sperm under the
assumption that it's never gonna come
back to you like you're it's a it's a
final thing so with these new websites
like opening that up I'm surprised that
there isn't more conflict around that
because it is kind of immoral like he
like this guy signed is lucky
completely and I feel like it would be
one thing if it was like a dad who like
you never knew who your dad was he
walked out and you were like you sound
like you come from a very like fulfilled
home life I give great parents to moms
who love you like a brother like I don't
know maybe you just be happy with what
you have but then it's also weird to
know that like your dad's someone out
there who had shares the same piece of
you know totally like your 50% of them
so I don't I really don't know I feel I
feel like I just wouldn't personally
open up a can of worms but that's so
easy for you to say when like you know
who was right and I don't like like you
don't have to live with the mystery and
then like what if you know what if one
day like you however granting you wish
that you had reached out but at some
point it's like it's nature versus
nurture yeah like you can be born to
someone but I have no connection to them
and technically like you don't have any
biological connection to your mom but
like she raised you and like knows you
better than anyone and like you'll
always be her sick dog everyone is it
calm
combination of their nature and nurture
so like it would be interesting to see
like the nature side of you but I don't
know I just don't think you're gonna get
what you're looking for and it doesn't
sound like you're looking friends right
and so I think just being curious yeah
right so I think you more like you might
wind up like just disappointed
especially if you like what if he did
which like you very well could be and
you have all these like half siblings
now and if they if meeting them didn't
do anything for you and like make you
feel like connected towards them I don't
I don't know that you'll find it yeah if
there's not something missing don't go
looking for anything that's how you get
like that's how you find out things you
don't want to find out you know if
you're fulfilled at home just leave it
alone I think ya know it's like so weird
to tell someone like not to ever meet
their dad you know yeah it's so it's so
weird like I so I don't have we're
undecided but I'm leaning towards now
I'm leaning towards no to if you just
like want to know what we would I but I
don't know what I would do in that
situation cuz I'm not in that situation
from the outside looking in I would say
no just cuz like it seems like you've
got it going on and like why go seek out
disappointment right no no if it ain't
broke from a man who like donate his
sperm ten plus time so like it's not
like this was his why now why this sperm
you know so like if it ain't broke don't
go find her that right next to your
Claudia Jackie this is labeled tattoo
drama my brother started tattooing up
his body recently pretty heavily it's
not a problem in general he's successful
grown man 33 years old who can do
whatever he wants my siblings and I know
about the tattoos but he's kept him a
secret like a seven-year-old child from
my mom and dad because they specifically
because specifically my mom to tests
tattoos since we were little our mom has
been saying that we break her heart if
we ever got tattoos trying to guilt-trip
us not into not having them so it makes
sense that my brother hid them from her
however he wasn't exactly hiding them -
well because somehow my mom saw a
picture of him tattoos and all on social
media she dramatically called me and
explained what she saw how mad she was
how stupid she thinks the tattoos looked
and so on the worst of it is twofold
she refuses to confront my brother
saying he should be the one to tell her
and that she certainly isn't bringing
the news to my dad and she's sort of
blaming his current girlfriend whom we
normally love get along with really well
because she has had to use and she feels
like that was a major reason he started
to get them so he gave my brother the
heads-up that my mom knows so we can
stop hiding the tattoos and just talk it
out with her or stay out of it knowing
that this could go on for years if
neither of them
bring it up to one another if it's real
but it's a real you don't get the
servants but it's a do they know that we
know that they know situation which is
the friends my friends thanks for the
help ladies my sister and I are testers
we love you bust a [ __ ] out of
everything but like they need to have
this come they need to move on like it's
yes she'll be disappointed and it'll be
a fight but like they'll get over it
like it's all get past it and the longer
like he hides it from her and she knows
like it's just it's unnecessary
like strife between so this isn't like
that dramatic it's a tattoo it's not
like a disease and it's like life shorte
be honest and I don't I'm always of the
mindset stay out of it but if you're
gonna get involved you have to you can't
be like mom knows and then you tell mom
I told mom that they know that you know
you literally set them down and be like
yo Jason whatever the [ __ ] your name is
mom knows you have the tattoos and then
leave and let that handle it's not your
pretty and it's like in general I say
stay out of it when it comes like friend
drama but like with your family you're
able to get into it if you think it's
for the benefit of the whole family and
so if your brother's like doing well and
he's tattoo proud and like this is who
he has been like your mom'll accept that
it's just like a big pill to swallow
initially because like there was one
thing she asked me not to do right and
like just respect your mom but obviously
you don't so right so it is what it is
now she already knows that part so is
that so funny how like people could have
like a totally different body under
their clothes and like you don't even
know no tattoos are like so crazy
you'll be blue hot tattoos I think it's
so crazy cause like that's like your
body like you literally are never gonna
show this part of your body to someone
right isn't where it is weird but it's
unless it's like on the bottom of your
foot right
yeah hiding like a small one but I
thought you meant like people out in
work who like cover up that hat like
[ __ ] wear a suit every time you don't
know that their whole chest is covered
in tattoos it's just funny like they
really have dual personality it's cause
like you envisioned someone who has
tattoos it's like a badass guy and then
someone in a suit who's like you know
buttoned up worker guy and it's like if
you have tattoos I could obviously
something you feel like so strongly
about it that you want to like advertise
it on your body and it's like what are
those things you feel so strongly about
what is it that's not only do I want to
know do you have tattoos it's like what
what do they name also what do you stand
for I think it's funny how like people
who have like a million tattoos are like
macho juiceheads but like if you like
ask some all the tattoos are like
meaningful and like are paying respect
to summer the memory of someone are like
their face so yeah
it's like there's so much gym but like
all these like [ __ ] writings on them
you know and also I think you could tell
you brother like if he is already like
tatted-up and gonna get more and
whatever tell them to get one for his
mom that would be cute oh my god that's
a great idea
right and then it's like if it's sad it
soften the blow
Wow well that's like the first real good
advice we've ever given that's been
especially if he's gonna get more
tattoos anyway like and then he'll be
like I will have you with me forever
love it get mom just like a hard yeah on
your shoulder if you had to get one
tattoo and you couldn't like it was like
you just had to ok thought about this a
lot cuz I'd like a really cute idea
because I would get a Hebrew word that's
so cute and I would get Misha Baha
underneath oh no I'm a hominid I was
just like writing it I wish my hot which
means family and maybe I would get it um
I wouldn't want it to be visible if we
had like a personal thing yeah um so
like the ankle but that's so tacky like
oh my god I'm sorry gonna room with an
equal tattoo it wasn't tacky when you
did it but now everyone has them maybe
I'll get Lukesh Mahavir my butt crack
that's cute I never really like thought
about it but now it's like actually
there's so many things I could hear oh
my god that's hilarious
no oh jeez oh well I used to think like
maybe I'm feeling like a symbol or
something cute like that but no I think
I would honestly get Stevie vibes you
would have to I would have to and like I
intend to be Stevie forever like I don't
think we're ever I guess like we say
things and they phase out bobble though
never will not be the time where we're
not executing Seanie buds right and like
even if like in ten years that we forget
that we were once teens like I always
have a reminder of this time our lives
when we were just eeny as hell and I'll
always know what they totally like the
white ones those like freak me but I
also don't know where I would get it
st. marqs they do like legit oh you
can't it like here that's always like oh
I like that except like I'm a role that
you have to have like a good sight over
where unless ribs if you're Alexis red I
have like too many roles there and my
boots I drew blood my said we would be
covering my dad too that's hilarious
yeah um okay this our third and final
one it's a little rated R so if you're
under 18 maybe it's time for you to shut
off this program it's called threesome
SL s you're under 18 get to get back to
class totally snitches even here touched
in school it's so hard without ever
dear toasters I recently found out oh I
believe now now that my boyfriend of
four years had a threesome with two
girls a year before we met I found out
when we were asking random silly
questions about one-night stands it was
obvious that he was hiding something so
I kept crying at him to tell me what it
was he finally got mad and told me that
he had had a threesome before we met I
was shook I ran to our bedroom trying to
process what he just said he followed me
in explain that he never told me because
he knew and be upset and he just wanted
to avoid that I asked him before if he's
out of threesome and he told me no I
also found out that a majority of my
boyfriends friends knew about the
threesome it makes me feel like everyone
knew but me I'm pretty straight edge
when it comes to life clearly so don't
really have any scandalous scandalous
you smell that wrong in my past that can
help me relate to this I know it
happened before we met but I didn't
think he was that kind of person it
makes me feel like there's another side
to him that I knew nothing about my
questions are I mean being dramatic that
this makes me upset or am i right my
feelings how do I move past this without
seeing my boyfriend differently we've
been dating for four years and couldn't
imagine my life without him I don't want
to end things help a toaster out I mean
the fact that you think about ending
things like you're a [ __ ] psycho I'm
sorry like the only problem I have with
this is that he lied about it
did he lie matter yes she's a mom she
asked he said no oh I don't think it's
weird that he had a threesome like
people like I know very sexually active
people it's like nah I mean I've never
had a threesome but like good for people
had and like who are comfortable in
their skins are like spread their legs
to two people let alone one at the same
time know when it's like until you know
someone who's had a threesome it's like
threesome like that only happens right
but I know somebody's a threesome it's
like honey yeah and it's like try to
feel it it's a part of being a
millennial sorry like everyone has
threesomes like nothing right and I
think most people other than people who
like engage in a menage tois culture on
the regular most people just do it once
and it's like there's their funny like
story well you know he got it out of his
system
so I think like you're being so dramatic
thinking he's a different person and you
need to relax but you do need to discuss
like the whole lying thing that's a
problem right yeah that he could like
just lie about it but that's a big
that's a big thing on the side if you
love him and everything else is good
this is not a deal-breaker whatsoever
yeah and you've got to chill out like
you need to honestly you need to have a
threesome to get back at him wait and
get you a girlfriend like what do you
think that the one-three-seven like got
him hooked on threesomes and out for the
rest of his life he's gonna every time
you leave every time you leave for the
weekend he's like out here sleuthing on
tinder for threesomes right I don't
think
so no no definitely not and like you're
being way too dramatic asal but like I
would want to just like know all that it
was gonna say now I need to know who it
was like the girls what were their
positions Eiffel Tower
what were the dynamics yeah two boys one
girl are just old friends boy how did
like how did this threesome feel like a
threesome like you can never see the
person ever again or they have to be
like your best friends like actually
it's like Dan and Vanessa and Hilary
Duff having a threesome
that was weird like one person was up
that like I would just want to have on
the information no want to be like gotta
like start and do the tape
oh yeah welcome to your tape I need to
see it yeah but also you have a lighten
up a little bit maybe you like me here
before you met like what do you like
everything will change now and he's
faithful that's all that matters and
like what guy is gonna turn down two
three songs no totally I'd be more like
I'd be like oh my man Big Pimpin good
for you right no you get two girls into
bed and you chose me you chose me
no but I would just like need to know
everything stalk the girls yeah find out
see where they're now maybe we could all
go to lunch and go to the clinic and get
a toast to bed yeah literally no you
need to have a threesome now that's your
thing
cuz this obviously you need to lighten
up a little bit yeah the two of you
could have a threesome with one other
person right do you think that when like
a couple like a man and a woman like a
hetero hetero
what does hetero straight were
heterosexual that's like a long word
that sounds wrong do they wanna add a
row sexual has a threesome with a man
that's weird I think it depends on the
couple but it's like took two straight
dudes
I'm not letting Fredi know I'm like
every time I like I'm like bet unless
every threesome with a man and he's like
no but it's like what are the buzz my
options
yeah what let someone skinnier come in
hello hello someone more flexible
someone were exploratory now someone
what to do hey don't you want have a
threesome we're getting another man it's
the only way yeah and then we're gonna
go Chippendale yeah and then it's shut
down right yeah no the conversations
over right but it's like but it's like I
think the the formula for a threesome
these days for like I had a real couple
is with another woman right but like but
that woman's like so the the female in
the relationship like has to be
comfortable with that otherwise right
and I think it's more common for like a
woman to be more comfortable with a
woman than like a straight man to be
working for with a straight man yes I
agree with that because boys are like
bro oh wait what am I thinking about
when someone got a [ __ ] from a man
and some on the show
samer house oh yeah Karl um well
[ __ ]
we're so x-rated today we're you know
yeah I'm glad you gave that disclaimer
for the a-team yeah no celeb ah not that
I want more deer toasters about
threesomes but like I just want more
interesting dynamics EB had tattoos
never spoken about that we had family
adoption never spoke about that we had
threesomes ever spoke about that I just
want to move on from like The Bachelor
co-worker
mean boss formula that we've passed
formula I agree um anyways what was on
TV last night Dallas I caught up okay
but I didn't watch all sighing okay but
i watch the episode that you were
talking about and I mean like leeanne's
jealousy of Brandi and Dan just so real
but then like this episode they get more
into like D'Andra and like how she's not
like being herself and how Brandi like
brings that out and her she was like
Brandi he's just like who she is doesn't
care what anyone else thinks I'm like I
need more of that in my life should I
grew up in a society with like oilmen
your husband now at like 50 years old
like she is ready to be herself which is
like really cute and I feel like that's
like her husband like encouraged is that
I'm her cuz they've only been married
for four years so now it's like he wants
her to just like let loose and so I
really do enjoy their friendship I do
the a nice like just stop being jealous
and we'll hear what she has to say
because she's coming on the show next
week oh yeah and Lee and Brandi need to
bury the hatchet because when they were
friends I love that the best thing ever
fur also it says next week's episode
like Leeanne told Kerry that he and her
only has two hundred dollars in her bank
account because like her mom is holding
her trust fund hostage and that's why
she like won the relation the
dissolution of her relationship and
level really shopping but she didn't get
that necklace because like then she only
had $20 left but you'll see on this
week's episode Brandi and the gals
bought her the necklace for her birthday
oh my god that is so dry yes and the
wood the way that Brandi presented it
they just showed us she was like this is
from hoochie mamas and it sounded like
she was a before her but then Brandi and
Stephanie and Carrie were on watch I was
having last night there we all chipped
in who's there any tea Mama's like I
think Brandi I don't know what Brandi
man but I think she meant on behalf of
for the hoochie-mama community cuz now
Deandra is joining hoochie mamas
everywhere who was the hoochie mamas I
think it's just like their inside joke
like Brandis turning Deandra into
hoochie mama so she was like on behalf
of OCC men that like just great it was
unclear and then 17 carry we want you to
know and they want all of you to know
that they chipped in on the gift that is
so sweet and really sad - I know and
like it doesn't seem like tangelos
denying next week's episode she's just
like - Leeanne why would you tell people
that you know that's really [ __ ]
[ __ ] on a TV show right but it's like
so crazy like D'Andra
technically is the witch is a righteous
one but like cash poor right but I find
that rich people are always cash poor
right it's actually weird that's so not
true
but it's like how is she paying her
Highland Park bills maybe she needs to
show
that's why she's stepping it up that's
why she's on the show it's always so
interesting something like why is
Cameron Wescott on this show I still
don't haven't figured it out I won't be
surprised she's like - borz Harnish the
family name I agree like a la countess
LuAnn like because when you watch she's
in one countess she was at the top she
lives in a [ __ ] four by which she
married her husband put her on the show
to get rid of her
camille Grammer husbands put did wives
on the shows a lot and I find it so
weird that they would like let her like
smear the good westcott name by being
literally the worst housewife in history
of all franchises I absolutely despise
her joke with her kids on last night's
episode being so anyway I can't stand
her almost the way that like we talked
to Theo but it's like one these are
people and to like we're we're Joker
that's watching like I wouldn't do that
for ten minutes straight
what knowing that someone has to watch
us on their television and when she
references herself in third person as
mommy like a hundred times did you see
mommy and daddy go to fever Beavercreek
I totally want you to think that Mommy
know that Sparco dog more than she loves
children
no she's literally she's actually so if
she didn't abort I won't be surprised um
no but there were a few moments in the
past two episodes where she's being like
a little bit funny she rode the bull
they went to the rodeo and it looked
insane we have to go and then get they
all got on the bull and they're like
riding Leon is a carnie kid like she's
been bull like she's an expert she's
like yeah it's all on the knees
Cameron gets on the bullet like her
Alison Olivia maxi dress and her cow
pink cowboy boots and they like getting
her out there she's so tall like it and
she was be nice but she was not being
like shy about like having to straddle
this bowl and she gets on and they were
going so slowly and she's screaming it
was actually really funny and she looked
so pretty and then she was just closed
she was her heel it was like her pink
like a cereal dress against the bull it
was just like a moment a dalit I feel it
I feel it and I could she's really
embracing like the text and stuff this
season yeah which I appreciate like I
don't need to see like the same things
that I see on the OC like charity at
least right what makes like Dallas
Dallas and they're doing more of that
separate like would you enter the
carnival and she got proposed to right
they went to the stockyards and I it was
just like a really cute I agree with you
on that but like Stephanie and Cary
didn't go and like they really missed
out especially some why didn't they go
um
Stephanie didn't go cuz she was on
vacation with her family and Kerry
didn't go because she said that she's
too bougie for the rodeo which is fair
it was definitely it was definitely down
and dirty but she doesn't even have the
nicest house right and I don't
understand she ripped out her she gutted
her entire house like for her closet and
then just round up redoing everything
but like doesn't it just make more sense
to get a new house yes at that point yes
so I don't understand people like
connected to their homes it's like like
Kyle Richards and she she never should
have moved no cuz she got burglarized
it's because of the the security system
that Teddy Mellencamp's husband put in
did you hear the tea on what the drama
is in Beverly Hills right now
no but it's actually really crazy so
Dury and Lisa Vanderpump are fighting
because we said Vanderpump to readapted
a dog from Vanderpump dogs and the dog
was obviously you know like a rescue so
it bit two of two of her kids will go
through them so she gave it she put gave
it to a shelter and Lisa was like so
upset
what kind of shelter I don't know but
like I guess least was upset that she
didn't return it to man her pump dogs so
and then she just like gave it to a
shelter and that like makes Lisa's
business look bad but it's like that's a
real fight that's a real fight but also
I don't know what side I take on that
because van remember be allowing dogs be
adopted into homes with kids if they're
like aggressive and it's like terrible
but if a dog like is aggressive like it
is supposed to be euthanized
not that I ever like recommend that but
that is like that's bad but Vanderpump
dogs did but like why didn't you just
give it back to Lisa right I don't know
I'm sure we'll find out on the season
but like that's so crazy because I've
been like ready for the dissolution of
dureena Lisa no I just
Lisa need to be taken down so every
person who goes against her I'm here for
it I don't care right it is I took their
side no matter what
right and the sacrificial dog like it's
crazy it's a small price to pay for the
takedown of Lisa Vanderpump agree that's
it ah anyways what a day what a life
what a time we're back tomorrow I gotta
figure out what to do about my trip
that's what but maybe maybe I will be
here Monday we'll say right but both are
great options Yom Kippur is on Wednesday
so yeah we're back at next week every
day except Wednesday I'm so dreading the
guy literally think about young people
are all year long I'm like I count how
far we are and I'm like me too it's like
it's here it's so it's like the opposite
of your birthday where it's like the day
after your birthday you're like so upset
your birthday's so it's so far away the
day after your own compares the best day
ever you don't have to figure and the
day after then people I'm like wow it's
already next year but till we have to do
it again
it's not a long enough no it's like I
constantly am thinking about Yom Kippur
but not even that you have to fast it's
like the day is supposed to be very hard
and depressing and sad cuz you're
supposed to really like feel the
atonement for all your sins so you can
go into the New Year being like a
refreshing for a new person but you
can't get to that place without the
church right so it's not even that you
can't it's like you really are not
supposed to like drive watch TV like be
happy like you're really just to pray
you're supposed to sit with your family
and like talk like it's just [ __ ]
torture right but you do come out like
feeling better but no but that meal
where you have so many bagels
yeah it's so good I just remember last
time using my phone oh my god hi Ben
this is your wife Claudia I'm a morning
show host and I'm live right now can I
help you this better be an emergency
it's not supposed to be over by 11:30
premium content Never Sleeps
you can't put a time stamp by the me I'm
content was it an emergency no of course
not is it ever
oh we were talking like young people
were um last year went like not using my
phone like I really really felt it I'm
actually like looking forward to a break
from my children but it was a lot harder
than I thought it was like I was having
more issues with the phone than with the
eating I know that you big is always by
problem the eating gets really bad like
around like 4 o'clock and also the night
before like not eating after dinner
that's like when I do my best eating no
that's the best time to eat right so
it's like if you do like watch TV or
like walk pass a bus add that I was like
like a commercial for food it looks
delicious it's really not honestly the
rest of the year like when I watch
commercials with the food like I
appreciate that I can eat Jackie I never
forget how I felt on Yom Kippur no I
always think I'm like wow in a couple
months I'm gonna be watching a
commercial and be like damn I wish I
could eat that right so I should and I
keep just reading today no and it's like
the key is waking up late so the morning
is the toughest yeah I I can sleep
really late and then we'll go to just
like go - we'll come home yeah hopefully
um but yes so big a week for us I am
here tomorrow and we'll see you about
the rest of the week tomorrow is our
anniversary special in the show oh right
Anthony batts because this Anthony
Vasquez is coming we're gonna have
exclusive photos from Claudia's wedding
cuz it's why when your wedding special
show where my veil again yes okay she
been come and also some photos from my
engagement to get myself excited I'm
starting to do wedding stuff and like I
still don't feel like a part or us
unbelievably torturous but the people
that I'm working with her making it a
lot easier truly but there's no way
around the torture and it's like yeah
people working the wedding industry like
they really love what they do and it's
like I can't imagine doing this I know
people who work in the body mystery or
some of the nicest most kind and loving
and helpful and generous people and they
also know how torturous it is like for
the people going federal they want to do
is help right and they love their chops
and like it really got no no that's
that's what I said like a year ago like
when I went to Bridal Fashion Week and
regular Fashion Week like the difference
was just so stark and so wonderful yeah
and I will always any Bridal Fashion
Show I get immense you will always go
yeah but it's like it's so crazy other
people like most of the people at the
bridal fashion shows like half of them
won't be there next year because they're
only Brides like for a year I thought
the same thing but I've never had babies
I got invited oh really okay I think you
need to be both I thought I was like
this is so sad it's my only brown finish
week but I got the invites again this is
so sad cuz I
not gala last year's invitation and then
and Mikey is going my wedding planner
and he's gonna take me and like finally
little Bridal shine but I'm not here
where are you I have to go down like I
just can't
yeah it's legit I mean better been twice
and it's like the most
that's where I met Michelle and Mike he
was like well next year you won't be a
bride I'm like yay but also like Oh
Jackie that's where you met Larimer and
that's where our whole life started
yeah they were she was at Ben Higgins
they just got engaged
wow what a lifetime ago what a lifetime
ago so thank you all so much for
listening we are now available on
Spotify which is so exciting so you can
now watch the morning toast if you want
to watch it Facebook and YouTube YouTube
I recommend YouTube and we're eventually
gonna transition strictly to YouTube so
i highly recommend we livestream Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
the Millennial morning show we're
talking about all the things you truly
care about recapping arrives we got me
bachelor taking down let me take down
taking them adores down revive revolve
down but if you are podcast gal you can
listen to us on soundcloud if you have
an Android that podcasts or if you have
an iPhone and now we are platform
agnostic because we can be listening to
one spot if I were to I'm so excited
because now I'm gonna listen on Spotify
so make sure to follow us on Spotify
also subscribe to us on iTunes so we can
beat the Joe Rogan podcast I amaryl host
Claudia I'll try girl to a job please
follow me on my personal Instagram
account club and no job I am Jackie ash
right at Jackie O problems please follow
me there I just worked out my highlights
I saw it's really pretty so cute
toasters obviously helped me toasters
come through for everything join our
morning toasters Facebook group
admission is slow because we need to vet
their snitches and Jackie really takes
time to look at every single person we
have 3000 pending requests but we'll get
there I go sigh except a couple people a
day I declined more people than that a
day and honestly the quickest way to get
into the group and this isn't just like
to show for us is if you join the toast
after dark which is the patreon group I
can see that I know you're legit and
you're in the toaster and also like put
time and effort into your answers when
people are hiding about podcasts which
favorite episode nd like no and if you
had one word you mean to client
paragraphs say something that makes me
know that I know that you know that we
know that you knew our toaster true
enough in the heart and soul because
anyone can fake it love you guys
you